now let's just get it over with let's
just talk about it let's address the
elephant in the room my background has
changed I know nothing else is going on
here okay
I am still the same I am still the
lovable old 2014 pewdiepie nothing has
changed
damn it I'm just the same goddamn poet
today we're playing the greatest game of
all time aim studio the media has given
me a lot of labels a lot of names but
people don't really know it's that I'm
extremely misogynistic miss agent miss
miss honor gist our high score is 16,000
today we're gonna beat that high score
pawpaw
ho ho ho that ass what's the word for a
jump big big vagina because in Sweden we
call a bullfighter what do you called it
in English cuz that was said that was
definitely a bullfight that ball [ __ ]
okay well alright well I guess it's as
simple okay
thick-ass we're going with thick asses
today boys and girls because I am NOT a
misogynist Attucks so basically if
you're new to this game you basically
run a camstudio with the women our goal
today is to become the greatest cam pimp
studio of all time and we're our niche
our niche is gonna be thick assets what
if we could only go with thick asses and
Latinas all right so we're gonna have to
take how do i play I forgot [ __ ] you
drag them right all right there you go
now remember all right we're making a
lot of money on this [ __ ] this is great
probably should have done this
cake farting think about this thick
asses cake farting we're gonna make
millions we're gonna make millions here
today bros all right great now we can
hire another girl please Donna a Latina
with the gasps please a thick ash all I
ask is for us I guess
I think ash please can I get a thick ass
all I ask and for us the gas all I ask
gyum milf tattoos damn it Nadia get the
[ __ ] yeah we're Tiffany Tina get the
[ __ ] out of my office Tiffany okay we
got Asian god damn it
chubby that's close enough
belly you're hiring let's now start
eating that chocolate we need one more
higher please
give me that ass give me that ass
[Music]
otherwise we're gonna have to broaden
our horizons okay we got Audrey teen
flat chest just go
Audrey just go all right we got little
Leilani Asian Fletch except what kind of
business do you think this is Leilani go
Sara chubby I still remember that moment
they all look so damn happy to me [ __ ] I
forgot I got to pay them [ __ ]
great now I'm [ __ ] broke great I hope
you're happy you got to pay people now
what the [ __ ] is this
okay we can get a new item all right
whatever guys we got cocaine we got one
yes but plug now we can hire someone
else what do we got
Zoe oh my god Zoe you look like you come
from the Fifth Element we got Audrey
Audrey for the second goddamn time go
just go
Tiffany god damn it listen listen you're
hired
but for one reason to wear this blood
plug up your [ __ ] that's right and
then buy me some [ __ ] liquor that's
right people don't understand how hard
it is to do what I do you don't notice
that I have to be tough with my girls
because otherwise it's gonna be too hard
for me when I have to fighter them all
right we're gonna have to promo chubby
we're going with chubby thick asses [ __ ]
I gotta pay these hoes this is not good
this is not good
[Music]
shut up we're fine we're fine everybody
no one panic we're fine all right we got
chubby and thick ass that's our main
goal
[Music]
Shelby milf
come here mama
wait Kiana cost two dollars an hour two
dollars an hour what do you think I'm
some kind of millionaire two dollars a
[ __ ] hour are you kidding me
Kiana two dollars an hour what do you
think money just grow some three trees
get that thick ass out of there
Tiffany one dollar she gets paid one
dollar an hour to wear a butt plug and
buy cigarettes yes Tiffany you're my
main [ __ ] now you're my main [ __ ] I
take it all back
someone is running my business to that
3232 dollars an hour what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you god damn it I've never
been this pissed in my left all right we
got Candice huge tits fit yes
but sixty four dollars an hour
Candice go [ __ ] yourself Nikki you look
like tumblr shut you up Nikki I just
spicy one dollar Nick in your heart
you're hired Nikki you're welcome to the
family Nikki I owe them so much [ __ ]
money
Jesus Christ
[Music]
just see it's now sixty-four dollars an
hour Jesse Jesse Jesse Jesse I need you
to I fire people
what is this Human Resources stopping me
why what's stopping me from firing these
[ __ ] I can't even I can't even pay
you guys this is really [ __ ] bad oh
my god no this is real bad this is real
bad this is you're not [ __ ] finished
until I [ __ ] tell you them if this
continues I'm gonna have to send Tiffany
out there in front of the camera and if
that ever happens that's when I know
I've lost it all
you
I need Tiffany out there all right this
is not gonna work out otherwise 127
[ __ ] dollars a [ __ ] hour what the
hell
Jesse Shh you're ruining my business I
need you to stop I need I just say I
need you out I need you to [ __ ] I need
you out and it just say it hurts it
hurts air hurts
you're out [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I still
ain't got no money
tiffany tiffany shut the [ __ ] up tiffany
tiffany go to this sleazy hotel do not
contract any STDs whatever the [ __ ] you
do
thank God
we need another [ __ ] for another [ __ ] I
mean lady lady we need another lady [ __ ]
I own so much money [ __ ] come on come on
jacksepticeye come on jacksepticeye yes
yes okay now now we're gonna invest yes
we're making progress here we're making
a bold move listen up Jesse
here's some cocaine all right some might
think it's unethical to give your
employees cocaine I say have you heard
of productivity
now go shake that ass shake that ass oh
my god I owe so much money Jesse if you
run me out of business I will never
forgive [ __ ] jesse side of cocaine
well someone give Jesse some goddamn
cocaine okay alright alright here's
what's gonna happen
you get two condoms that's right you
better oh go to this sleazy hotel and
work your magic
do not get STDs Sarah caught AIDS
[Music]
hello darkness my old friend goddammit
if she has AIDS can she still be a cam
girl ah aids girl make me that money
haha you know it's kind of inspiring how
you know despite having AIDS and all
she's still doing her job she's still
living her day-to-day life this came
true leus and inspiring Sarah ran out of
steroids yeah well you should have
thought about that before you got AIDS
how do i cure AIDS I don't understand
surely there must be a way unless we
find a cure for AIDS we're gonna go down
real [ __ ] fast final day come on come
on work harder show me some Tani's it's
9 p.m. at 11 at 11 p.m. I'm sending
everyone through the whorehouse to get
that last bit of cash Jesus Christ it's
11 p.m. islets know I didn't get to sell
it to the whorehouse did I beat my
record
did I be I made my record
and only we only got AIDS and that was a
goddammit oh [ __ ] you